I have spent many hours in these pews
but not attending church I was attending
performances here at battelle and maybe
the performances weren't my first choice
more performance pay back showing up to
support the people who had shown up at
my events and performances just like
some of you are doing here today and
maybe sometimes I would stack my
evenings of performance pay back to
start here and then it intermission go
to Calhoun to catch the second half of
something and end the night with the
beginning of a comedy show at styles and
I would try at each performance to pay
really close attention to one detail so
that I could bring it up in conversation
with the person the next time I saw them
to prove that I was there and fine as
sometimes at performances here at Patel
I would be in the balcony doing homework
at the same time because I fall asleep
at chamber music events and the Opera
but the thing is I owed my friends
because they had shown up at my life and
performances and protests even if they
didn't care much about what I was doing
they turned out so I turned out for them
and this sense of reciprocity and owing
is part of what's going on in today's
story from Luke which on the surface
seems rather innocuous but is a pretty
great snippet of political maneuvering
healing miracles are just so hard for
modern audiences especially modern
audiences with an affinity for
evidence-based medicine but just go with
me on the fact that healing miracles
were a thing in the ancient Near East or
at least it was a thing people told
story
about and any good religious sect had
its healing miracle worker and healing
miracles were a thing with value they
almost had their own capital and if a
healing was done by someone outside your
sect your sect then owned them so it was
in the best interest of your group to
have your healing miracle worker do
healings for people outside of your
organization now and then so that you
could have the upper hand i remember in
psych 1 10 / in street hall with a
professor now president-elect salivate a
lecture about the case study the Hari
Krishna's giving out carnations in the
airports and how it created this sense
of owing on the part of the recipient
even though they weren't asking for
money there was this sense of I have a
creative carnation and now I'm indebted
to these vegetarians and colorful robes
who were part of the Beatles lesser
works and you felt like you owed them
something it was a brilliant way to
create this dynamic and there's
something of that going on in today's
reading from Luke the Jewish community
in Capernaum is in debt to this
high-ranking Roman official this century
and a century and is like a local police
chief he's got a decent salary but a
really good pension and this particular
centurian had personally contributed to
the financing of the local Jewish
communities synagogue so they owed him
and so when he is in the in need of a
healing the local Jewish community
intercedes on his behalf and says to
Jesus basically look he built our
synagogue we owe him a healing and local
Jewish communities didn't always claim
Jesus as their own but in this case it's
a way they can rebalance the political
skills so you got a synagogue for
healing as well but this is also a story
cashing in on political favor for
personal and emotional and some might
say completely irrational reasons
because the century enslave is just not
any slave it is a slave who is highly
valued or in other translations dearly
loved in fact it is a slave that the
Centurion cares for so dearly that he is
willing to expend the political capital
a building a building to have this guy
healed and in the absence of any other
details which we don't get from the text
it is not a shrewd move on the
Centurions part but i think that the
centurion is past the point of caring
about crafty political moves because he
has this one line where he's buttering
up Jesus by trying to describe them as
being both leaders with authority and he
says I also in the man set under
authority which soldiers under me I say
two one go and he goes and another come
and he comes and to my slave do this and
he doesn't and when I've read that line
I hear it with an ellipsis with a voice
crack I have all of these soldiers and
slaves under me and when I say jump they
say how high but this situation of
someone I care for being sick this I
cannot dictate or innovate my way out of
and maybe you all know something of what
it is like to come to the point where
you're coping mechanisms
and brain and power fail you and you are
willing to pay anyone even someone from
the outside to make it go away for some
of us it was coming here for the first
time and were some of us the first time
not being the best no matter how hard we
tried or for some of us it's coming back
to a reunion and possibly not measuring
up to some mythical metric we have
devised or it's an illness or a job
search or an addiction or relationship
in crisis or it is the sheer monotony of
another Monday that is the point when we
are willing to go to an outside miracle
healer and I have been the recipient of
a lot of miracle healing they're not
necessarily from an outside sect I'm
exceedingly proud to have earned a
degree from Yale but even now 10 years
later sometimes I think that I didn't
earn it because my suitemates edited
every paper I turned in and as proud as
I am to have had the jobs I have friends
of mine have provided marginalia on
countless resumes and get me through so
many mondays and I don't remember what
any of these people said in class here
in fact I don't even know if I took
classes with them though I'm sure they
were brilliant and said brilliant things
in them what I remember is them showing
up I remember them not mocking me when I
needed them I remember their help which
is to say that I remember when by force
of miracle they healed me and so I am in
their debt and I'm beginning to think
that maybe the point is the debt maybe
the point is not to innovate out of
needing one another and settling our
debts much less maintaining the upper
hand Kierkegaard has this great passage
in works of love where he talks about
how in the life of love and community we
are constantly in debt to one another
because to love is to stay in debt it's
the floating twenty-dollar bill between
friends and of course there are overly
needy people and moments and
opportunities where you set up
boundaries that Papa but mostly we are
always paying forward and backward and
side to side in human relationships in
some crazy debt web the sequestration
would have a field day with what we do
and it's not just that we can't get out
of being bound to and reliant on one
another but it's also that by allowing
others to heal us the other person gets
to participate in the life of God and I
forget that part by using our gifts
maybe gifts honed here we get to help
one another and to do healing miracles
that make us part of being Christ in the
world which is so ennobling and so
honoring to the lives that we live and
sometimes we need to be reminded that we
have been miracle healers
so as you go from this place back to
your weeks and lives i invite you to
think about who has been a miracle
healer for you what manager took the
time to invest in you who practiced with
you who didn't laugh at your question
who showed up and then came back the
next day and i invite you to thank them
with as much specificity as you can
muster i invite you to tell them these
things of how they were christ to you
because their lives are made up by
Monday's also and yes Sarge rahel is
other people but so is heaven and in
this life we do not pay off our debts
but some days we get to do some miracles